this episode is made possible by
curiositystream get free access to
nebula the streaming platform built by
all your favorite youtubers
when you sign up for curiosity stream at
the link below
the united states military the largest
most powerful
most dangerous fighting force on the
planet a military that hasn't been
involved in a defensive war since the
1940s
yet whose budget continues to balloon
every year
u.s military spending currently exceeds
that of the next 10 nations combined
we have over 600 military bases outside
our borders
occupying over 80 countries around the
world the united states
military while it tries to sell itself
as a force for freedom and democracy
is not a welcome sight in much of the
world our aggressive posturing bullying
and occupation has turned world opinion
against the us armed forces over the
past few decades
and it's not hard to see why when you
think of a modern fighting force
you typically think of tanks fighter
jets humvees drones and aircraft
carriers
but these giant death machines don't
operate on their own
the us military like any other relies on
recruits
americans willing to pick up arms and
kill for their country
in this episode we're going to take a
look at the state of u.s military
recruiting
and the shady tactics used by the armed
forces to rope in new soldiers
before we begin let's take a second to
discuss why the u.s feels like it needs
such a massive military
since the end of world war ii and
certainly since the end of the cold war
the united states has been the sole
world superpower this has given the
country the luxury of using that power
to clamp down on the world's economy
with an iron grip
the u.s relies on other countries
relying on it
if another country doesn't feel the need
to grovel for u.s assistance and trade
deals
the u.s military will often be called in
to create an environment
that forces that country to re-evaluate
if crippling sanctions aren't enough
boots on the ground certainly will be
but if the united states already has
such a stranglehold on the rest of the
world
why does the military budget keep
increasing a large part of it is to feed
the ravenous military-industrial complex
and deliver lucrative contracts to
companies like boeing
lockheed and raytheon but more recently
u.s officials have cited the possibility
of a great power conflict with china
that kind of talk should alarm us the
last great power conflict
though it never devolved into outright
war was the cold war with the soviet
union
during which time we almost caused
nuclear annihilation on multiple
occasions
before that it was world war ii if u.s
officials are gearing up to start
another war of this magnitude
the world is in for a very bad time with
this aggressive rhetoric becoming more
common
the u.s military has been adamant about
maintaining a fighting force of 500 000
soldiers
and this requires an intense recruiting
program
so how does the world's largest military
entice the next generation of soldiers
well these days it seems to be with
cartoons that appropriate inclusive
language
video games and taking advantage of
those in poverty
let's start with the video games i'm
sure you're all familiar with twitch
if somehow you're not twitch is the
largest live streaming platform in
operation right now
they bring in insane numbers of both
streamers and viewers averaging roughly
3 million concurrent viewers at any
given time
who watch a total of around half a
billion hours of content per week
that's a huge audience and a lot of time
spent on individual streams
which can run for hours as far as
demographics go
the audience skews young and male with
about 65 percent of viewers being male
41 between the ages of 16 and 24 and 73
between the ages of 16 and 34. to
military recruiters twitch is a dream
come true
you have a captive audience of young
impressionable viewers who tend to
develop parasocial relationships with
the streamers they watch
it's the perfect medium for young
charismatic recruiters to pitch the
military to the next generation
and they know this in 2018 the us army
launched its own twitch channel as part
of its new more modern approach to
recruitment
the navy followed suit shortly after in
the first six months of 2020
the military had bagged 13 000 new
recruiting
leads from twitch alone keep in mind
that many twitch users are underage
as you only have to be 13 years old to
make an account
so you have young incredibly malleable
children watching trained army and navy
recruiters play games like cod and
fortnite for hours on end
while they surreptitiously try to
convince their viewers to join the
military
if this sounds incredibly shady and
predatory that's because it is
and it gets worse early in their
streaming endeavors
the army esports mods would ban users
for asking about u.s war crimes
until they were eventually forced to
unblock those people after accusations
of first amendment violations
then there's the navy claiming that
their streamers aren't recruiters
despite the fact that they're required
to take the same training courses as
navy recruiters before they're
considered for the role
the army even went so far as to just
straight up lie and put up a link to a
fraudulent xbox giveaway
which when clicked instead took you to
an army recruitment information form
this was later taken down by twitch
hassan [ __ ]
one of the most popular leftist
streamers rightly accused these
recruitment practices as being predatory
shout out to hassan by the way thanks
for boosting my videos you should all go
watch him if you don't already
now twitch is just one cog in the modern
military recruitment machine
another shameful practice is
specifically targeting poor students who
have few opportunities
back in the 70s the new york times ran a
story about how
sergeant hard times is the best
recruiter in the world
rightly pointing out the fact that in
times of economic precarity
people are driven to latch on to
whatever opportunities they can find
this is still very much the case today
when job or life prospects are lacking
recruiters can weaponize that fear and
uncertainty to press young people into
service
one recent program offers the perfect
example of how the military targets
those in precarious conditions
in what's been dubbed focus 22 the
pentagon has selected 22 cities which
have large black and latino populations
recruiters descend on these cities like
buzzards stationing themselves in
schools and public places to try to
ensnare as many young people as possible
some cities like baltimore have allowed
the military to install their
march to success software on all the
city's public computers
this software is meant to look like a
study aid but it also collects user data
so that recruiters can track down
anyone who uses it if keeping a database
of a city's young people sounds bad
just wait till you hear about the
jammers database jammers
or the joint advertising market research
study is a billion dollar database that
catalogs the data of over 30 million
americans between the ages of 16 and 25.
this database was classified as top
secret until 2005.
preying on the poor isn't new militaries
throughout history have used their poor
as cannon fodder while the rich
those benefiting from the wars never
have to send their children to die
it's a hideous practice and it reflects
very poorly on this nation that so many
people feel like they have no
alternative
so we've seen soldiers trying to ensnare
underage gamers to become pawns in their
death machine
and government programs to collect the
peasants and ship them off to blow up
their fellow human beings on the other
side of the world
but there's one more aspect of the
military's recruitment initiative that
we should discuss
and in a surprising twist it's probably
the one that's gotten the most bad press
for as long as we've had a military
there have been propaganda campaigns to
try to convince citizens to enlist
for the last couple decades recruitment
ads have generally looked like something
out of blackhawk down or call of duty
big scary guys driving amphibious
vehicles rappelling out of helicopters
and running around shooting at bad guys
we never see
but in this most recent attempt at
winning over gen z
the army has taken a page out of the
cia's book and appropriated diverse
inclusive language as a way to say
hey we're modern and cool we're not just
a bunch of trigger-happy barbarians
we're just like you in a five-part ad
series titled the calling
the army shares what are supposedly
genuine stories from enlisted soldiers
but because the military knows that all
them young people care about is cartoons
they also animated the ads in a few
different styles
let's take a look at a few highlights
from the series
one time i snuck out and stayed three
days at a friend's place
when i came home mom wanted to teach me
to appreciate the life i had by sending
me to the dominican republic to stay
with relatives for a year
[Applause]
one day at school i came upon an army
recruiter
and told him about my goals he took me
through all their different careers
and that's when it hit me the army is an
army of good people
pay close attention to how seemingly
innocuous statements are phrased
i was bad so my mom sent me to another
country to see how bad it is compared to
the united states
when i came back i realized that the us
is the best country on earth and the
army is good because america is good
so as soon as i turned 17 i asked for my
dad's blessing to enlist
but having served in the army during the
vietnam era
responding to civil unrest he said no
he had his reasons i hope his reasons
were recognition of the fact that the
vietnam war was
just one long string of u.s war crimes
during which period we massacred
innocent people
dropped more bombs than during the
entire second world war
riddled the land with millions of mines
rained fire down on civilian populations
and used chemical weapons which are
still causing cancer and birth defects
to this day
all for a conflict we never should have
initiated in the first place
of course by the end of the ad dad is
proud of his little girl for joining
anyway
but it was one day during a 9 11
ceremony
i started seeing the army in a new light
over 3 000 students lined the walls and
the balconies of my school
my whole community was there including
firefighters and service members
from every military branch the silent
show of respect for this country
was stephanie i was now determined to
defend
this nation that i called home to not
only be a citizen
but a soldier as well this is another
common tactic
hey remember that bad thing that
happened look how strong it made us
look how respectful everyone is of the
flag and our country i'm gonna join the
army
of course there's no mention of the fact
that 911 was used as justification to
start an unjustifiable war
which claimed over a million lives
destabilized an entire region for
decades
and dragged on for so long that
americans who enlisted back then
have now been able to watch their
children go off to murder the children
of the people they didn't manage to kill
the us military-industrial complex is
very skilled at using the symbology of
the flag as a way to deflect blame
promote a victim complex and play up the
american exceptionalism myth all at the
same time
for many people this kind of ad can be
quite effective
but the one that got the most attention
and we'll explore why afterwards
is this one this is the story of a
soldier who operates your nation's
patriot missile defense
systems
it begins in california with a little
girl
raised by two moms
i like to think i've been defending
freedom from an early age
i needed my own adventures my own
challenge
and after meeting with an army recruiter
i found it
a way to prove my inner strength and
maybe shatter some stereotypes
along the way if you take a look at this
ad on youtube
or any of them really you'll see that
they got absolutely eviscerated by the
viewers
the like to dislike ratio is among the
worst i've ever seen
and of course the comments are turned
off because there likely wouldn't be a
single positive one
why did these ads flop so hard the army
managed to outsmart itself and alienate
all of their potential recruits those on
the political right are all up in arms
over the woke language
and outraged at the idea that the army
is trying to appeal to people who
clearly don't belong in the military
though it is funny to watch these
reactionary losers have their little
meltdown
what's more important is why the ads
fell flat for their target audience
younger more progressive members of gen
z trying to be more inclusive is good
acknowledging the validity of all sorts
of quote non-traditional backgrounds
is important but it shouldn't be
surprising that gen z
the most anti-war anti-capitalist
generation in decades
sees right through the propaganda i like
to think i've been defending freedom
from a young age
come on young people know what the us
military gets up to
they live on the internet they can find
plenty of evidence of the mountains of
war crimes the u.s commits
they're aware of past military policies
against gay and trans service members
but more than that they're aware that
being allowed to serve in the military
isn't some great victory for the lgbt
community
because no one should want to invade
other countries and oppress their fellow
human beings
no matter how hard the military tries to
rebrand itself as a woke force for good
freedom and democracy
no matter how cute they try to make
missile launchers most young people
won't fall for it
they know they're being targeted with
short eye-catching animated propaganda
of course these ads will appeal to some
young people
and they'll soon find themselves in a
situation that is nothing like what's
been presented to them
and that's a shame it's despicable that
the military has to steal data corrupt
underage stream viewers
target the poor and desperate and try to
sell a lie to meet their quota of cannon
fodder for a great power conflict the
united states so clearly wants
the military always has and always will
use shady
predatory tactics to fill their ranks
the best we can do is be aware of it
provide truthful information about what
joining the military really means
and work towards building a society that
doesn't funnel the poor
and the impressionable young into the
imperialist war machine
without soldiers to fly their drones
fire their rockets and drop their bombs
the military can't function it can't
bully the rest of the world
and that sounds pretty good
[Music]
if you'd like to see what great power
conflict looks like to truly understand
the horror
of world war i highly recommend you
check out apocalypse world war
ii on curiosity stream it's an
incredible six-part series about the
chaos and destruction of the second
world war
and it's so important that people
realize just how capable humans are of
destroying ourselves
curiosity stream is an established
streaming platform with a solid track
record of caring about great educational
content
and the financial security of those who
produce it they've got thousands of
non-fiction titles from some of the best
filmmakers in the game
as you probably know youtube doesn't
treat its creators very well
that's why some of my youtuber friends
and i teamed up to build nebula
so we don't have to worry about
demonetization as
educational creators ourselves we love
curiosity stream
so we've worked out a deal where if you
sign up for curiosity stream at the link
below
you'll also get access to nebula 100
free that's less than 15 bucks a year
for both curiosity stream and nebula
which in my humble opinion is a pretty
great deal since most of us are still
waiting for the vaccine
why not spend some time learning about
fascinating topics on curiosity stream
or check out nebula's original content
including my upcoming series on the
resurgence of fascism
you can also watch all my videos as they
were intended ad free
there really is something for everyone
and by signing up at the link below
you're helping us produce more content
without the fear of demonetization
give curiosity stream a shot and get
free access to nebula when you sign up
using the link below
it really does help support my channel
and educational creators all across
youtube if you enjoyed this video and
you'd like to see more like it
consider subscribing to stay up to date
with my latest episodes if you hated it
go ahead and drop a thumbs down you can
check out my previous episodes by
clicking the links on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week
[Music]